c'est pas une provocation mais c'est de
l'opportunisme politique pour bien
connaître laurent wauquiez s'est
absolument pas surprenants ce qu'il a
fait effectivement comme vous disiez il
est il en est à trois semaines de
l'élection de la présidence de des
républicains il est ultra favori c'est
une élection qui n'intéresse personne
personne vire je me mets ma main à
couper que les gens dans la rue c'est un
regrettable et autres participants voilà
une nombre de vols nombre de
participants à l'élection personne ne
connaît les candidats la mise à part
laurent wauquiez et encore et encore
donc c'est une manière habile
intelligente comme il est c'est
probablement l'un des mains des
policiers
quel plus beau cv de la république de
faire parler de lui de faire parler de
cette idée de faire l'idée clivante qui
vantent pas dans son corps mais kaki
ventes par rapport à maquereau puisque
c'est l'ennemi qu'il s'est identifiée
par rapport à la présidentielle 2022
donc voilà pour moi c'est plus de
l'opportunisme politique que un débat
idéologique sur la place de la laïcité
dans la république ou pas